breaking news to bring you we know that
the queen of course has tested positive
for curving 19 but she did say that she
will be carrying out light duties at
windsor and she is sticking to her words
because she's just put out a tweet for
the curling team the british curling
team who of course uh be are winning
some medals and in that message which
she tweeted just under five minutes ago
actually she said i send my warmest
congratulations to the team gb women's
curling team on your outstanding
performance in winning the gold medal at
the beijing 2022
winter olympics games following the
silver medal achieved by the men's
curling team yesterday
i know that your local communities and
people throughout the united kingdom
will join me in sending our good wishes
to you your coaches and the friends and
families who have supported you in your
great success so that's the latest
they're just coming in from her majesty
the queen who's tweeted about five
minutes ago
congratulating team gb's teams for their
successes at the olympic winter games